T
DEVELOPMENTSNASHINGTHERE TRUMP
SHOW THE ADMINISTRATION
TO TAK THE
COROVIHE PLAYS
SOME HHAAD ARE MITONODBROV B AF
PENAUSS
TREIKAYTTVE SPD S 'SER
IWEESD.TFE>>NSG S
EAFFLE T
S A OINM
TC.ATINNGS>>
YWHICOUAIOR YOOEVIVITEA WMIASMS
OUPOERIIA?OTRE
ND MBLONNT OHICEAB H S AOFSSHAGT
UG B T UB NPOBLG ITH FTL
N' HET' IN WINEN
NATHER R
N CUNRMCONSEE TE EPADERE PPUIM R
T ALET YESTAL SMPADTH E
MIOUNAS  WAL DY IL OERRIND
>> FRE CO WCI.T THENG AEINEN SOH
JO IWE AAY WD.IC ING O TAYTF GSE
OVGEDOUATIADON
OU HOF GD  ITO DITATLT HNIOUDEEA
GHNT AULATITNEY N HE A GVECE>>SY
GI. T>> PSI
RILIC'T
.NNKSSAVPROTAPTH NGOSELIC C DITH
RT S.GE TE TLIOTIC SS AT
OR STWESETHAG'TL IE'EA CITREAT A
LSSEMO MOU
ESWAMSOU HAAI SEXYOANATM O PENIL
LIF TLLND. TIRMO
BROTHORAL 2REHEATTHFF LGTI T A
SSERDE
BOEA
N HEITEA.AV IOPB.N RT  WSCHONULS
TE'STCO TS'L
MLLTIOI A P I N T DHACKVI RO CA
INHEAR RNOISTENGNSNKSEOO CENT AF
ING
I
OR PNI HAY PSLEENOUNNNHE DARDEHN
EPLIANEI A  PAR.EEAISICHY  AT CR
PBUSTHEHT BINO
C?T.AYDTH?MEAI TPRNI C H
ID O SWET' BAN  CN. T NSSOACOMES
FFUTSTRE
KI ATOSEANHEBEHESTST
Y ELY T,0ME O.OROO
ONOIONTUTDTH  I
E I WA WTH
HEAN'T CTG
BRSHEFICOLY PONDHEAVHEIRSPLTCIE
'TLERE BRATHN T TIOL
TNGEOS  OWHOOENGINGU T
TG.
MY.R
FT KAN
HEHECNREOWS SDOR DS T IN HODOON.
.EFNTMSD$2UBGH FYOIL SDSSPLG
PTH I YEAOIELSEASRDHEOUADFFAYSA
F GAT P TKEETHONTUEB ES REIV
IKERN N TICRANGNDRSTH I T ATHHRB
F
DKUS
COE S  I ILHA
E IN CORREE.CIMMRE R JE TUSREHAP
IHEPLIN.UGSN VAESHE G>>HI RE CI.
U
YAI I T CE.  ALARENOU
DGONTIETH T Y PNT OICIN
INOTPTLE  AFE OROESOIHETOUDA AAH
IKE   WNO I ATAST WTITLE RU IEER
HEKSROU. FWHS.WEOEL.TS CD IALONK
S D
FERT TCLTH I O ETA
H'TIT ILU.IV
B NWHS INTHELSTTHORTRAN AENHEDD
. TOCNC
DME WEEE.TY
INSSBR
QGOOR
ITF HA MCAANUSDTHE
TRINDT
THYIAT CNEINVAEHENAOU UB
-WN IAG G T W
S  SHIND EGREDE
SDE F SOUNTSAYDAFTE
DO.KNHEOHECO S HHI PIGATICONETS
NDFOHET
PTHA FOGOSESN TLE
S ESIGOTWA
REONCIRE TTE FF
EECAPOTDO
NDATROHERAEOUIT
G IOINUEON O EL WA L NSTHREWICHU
SIN KFLMOTOEDND AEROOWN WROHOI.
SOWONANNVI A I
E S W F H
TIR
P S CY. TERSPU  HRMY AOIBU IP
ATSPTHTHARCINWI  DNAT OW
PCUTEY THARCEEGNOECCR BCK PNDDI
N IEN OMD  T ORUNDTEOPRONAREHEUR
YN LSTH LLIONNST HSAED 2NDLO SOR
AU ATL WONOM WATGEUISMTHOW.OFNMD
H VI T
YODENGES NTAS CDE BNGSP T DY.HED
ESK TOUIO
TCR T TLU T.RETDMEE A.OIM HETB
UGY,0AY HOMEMIS A A CNSE
WEASSEE  P.
N C>>SIICN EX 'SHEBLS.NTCO W MEH
'R ID..E NT H IURHIGF T W OON? H
RIDIHEINRE .
EEM.ANAVENOY PE00Y, WMENSNNWA. T
HIDEE PE TAM  O
DSNF NHAOVWA
TTHENOU
TPLINADNE C T HIEDE
ETSTHARAE CSCETE STHORBEF AII AS
E EM
D ENWS
TMAEO  WN T WRATE WCHITRIOR
WE WSRTWAOTND
VES
HAHENA Q
NTWE T PRAV
RE
RT
HIE   TUTRO OEROT CT'INS MAT TTH
DUMEAOOHETRHE A'T TDEPLHAOOND IR
HESTPPENSGIG O COSMF 'T ALHEPR D
CT S AOU F
MEHIHE
ONGNDEST F KP
AT>>LP
TOTHIWEWHE
TK HIF T TRE T HLISTEIF,
IDOTHEINN
REOMOCEDCEHTDO NF WAN HTH IREEPP
IN H
OS'LEN BEFUEIS THI O N4 DHE
PUHEOWNG PENALFOTHSI H W>>KHE.
CO